(crowd cheers)
- We had a big day today
and don't let those cheaters
and crooks think anything different.
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] Republican candidates
who have echoed former President
Donald Trump's false claims
that the 2020 was fraudulent
lost some crucial races this election.
- That's right.
- [Narrator] While others
have not yet been called
by the Associated Press.
Election skeptic candidates
were on the ballot
for governor and secretary of state
across the country on Tuesday.
But in a few key swing states,
these offices could have the most impact
on the 2024 General Election and beyond.
That's because governors
and secretaries of state
have considerable authority
over election administration
and in 2020, Nevada, Arizona,
Michigan, and Pennsylvania
were all decided by thin vote margin.
Here's a breakdown of how
election skeptic candidates fared
in each of those states.
- This is a movement.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] In Pennsylvania,
Republican Doug Mastriano was defeated
in his race for governor
by Democrat Josh Shapiro,
according to the Associated Press.
As a state senator, Mastriano
introduced legislation
to ignore the 2020 election result
and directly appoint
electors pledged to Trump,
despite the fact
that there was no evidence
of widespread fraud.
- It's something very near and
dear to both of our hearts.
We're gonna fight like
hell for voting integrity
and we're gonna start with voter ID.
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] In Pennsylvania,
the governor directly appoints
the secretary of state
and other election officials
and therefore can significantly
influence election policy.
(tense music)
- Why do we have a secretary of state
that wants to go around the rules?
- [Narrator] In Michigan,
Republican Tudor Dixon
was defeated in her race for governor
by incumbent Gretchen
Whitmer, according to the AP.
During her campaign, Dixon
repeated false claims
that the 2020 election result in Michigan
was altered by widespread fraud.
If elected, she had pledged
to enact strict voter ID laws,
ban ballot drop boxes, and
launch retroactive investigations
into the 2020 election.
- We're insurrectionists, we're traitors,
big lie proponents for asking questions.
- [Narrator] And
Republican Kristina Karamo
lost her race for secretary of state
against the Democrat
incumbent Jocelyn Benson,
according to the AP.
Karamo ran on the America First
slate of election skeptics
and has repeated false
claims of election fraud.
The Michigan secretary of state
does not have the centralized authority
over election certification
that many other secretaries of state have,
but he or she can issue directives
to local election offices
and trigger audits,
as allies of President Trump did in 2020.
(bright tonal music)
- Is this the greatest
president we're ever known?
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] In Arizona,
the governor's race has
still not been called
between former TV anchor Kari Lake
and Democrat Katie Hobbs.
Lake was among the most visible
and vocal skeptics of the 2020 election.
She had aligned herself with Trump,
who made Arizona a focal point
of his false election claims.
- I'd actually like to ask
everybody on this stage
if they would agree we had
a corrupt, stolen election.
Raise your hand.
- [Narrator] Official
investigations, court cases,
and election audits have not
substantiated allegations
of widespread fraud.
In Arizona, the governor
and secretary of state
can enact sweeping changes to elections,
especially if their party controls
the state legislature too.
In her campaign,
Lake didn't specify all of
the changes she would make,
but she signaled
opposition to early voting
and mail-in ballots.
- Our Constitution says Election Day,
it doesn't say election
season, election month.
- [Narrator] The race for
Arizona secretary of state
has also not been called
between Republican Mark Finchem
and Democrat Adrian Fontes.
In Arizona, the secretary of state
is in charge of certifying elections.
As a state representative,
Finchem introduced legislation
to decertify the 2020 election,
and during his campaign
for secretary of state,
he often repeated unfounded
claims of widespread fraud.
- There are certain counties
that should've been set aside
as irredeemably compromised.
Maricopa County was one of them.
- [Narrator] In Arizona,
the secretary of state
has broad powers over
election administration.
Previously, Finchem had expressed a desire
to decertify many of
Arizona's election machines.
(serious tonal music)
- Your name, sir?
- Jim Marchant from Las Vegas, Nevada.
We are here to recommend
that you vote today
to dispose of your electronic
voting and tabulation machines
and do not use them in any
elections going forward.
- [Narrator] The race for
Nevada secretary of state
has still not been called
between Republican Jim Marchant
and his Democratic
opponent, Cisco Aguilar.
Marchant has made false claims
about the 2020 election.
- We have something in common.
President Trump and I
lost an election in 2020
because of a rigged election.
- [Crowd] Yeah!
- [Narrator] Ahead of the midterms,
Marchant led an organized campaign
to support election skeptic candidates
for secretary of state nationwide.
- Last year, I established a
MAGA America First coalition
of secretary of state
candidates around the country.
- [Narrator] Marchant's group,
the America First slate,
included a dozen candidates
for secretary of state
and supported the gubernatorial campaigns
of Kari Lake in Arizona and
Doug Mastriano in Pennsylvania.
(crowd cheers)
(crowd applauds)
- Oh yeah.
- [Narrator] Election skeptic candidates
lost some important bids to take the reins
of election administration
in swing states,
while others remain uncalled.
Changes to election processes
in any one of these states
could be the factor that tips
a close election in 2024.
(tense tonal music)